there's a lot going on down on bill
street tonight the place where the blues
began in memphis tennessee
i'm thinking about cutting it up a hound
though oh pounder
[Applause]
elvis you could not get a better life to
use as a canvas music the looks the
fashion and like carnival time he's
actually a symbol of culture
baz wanted to tap into elvis's iconic
style moments
we studied all the references to the nth
degree they make it all feel so so real
and it is real it's so essential to see
elvis watching little richard and he's
like
it was massive but influence you look at
the way that he dressed throughout his
career going back to the 50s the lace
shirts the flowing pants custom shoes
the 60s and black leather i also love
the white jumpsuit
[Music]
it was about finding the distinct shift
[Applause]
between periods i was lucky enough to
rekindle collaboration with prada and
mummy and mucha prada to tell the elves
story through
iconic design he was the catalyst for a
lot i think that was all just coming
from that spirit inside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you